now today i had the honor of
interviewing the president of the united
states who's
fighting his hardest to secure these
borders and he was down here as well
take a look
[Music]
rio grande behind us these are the guys
on the front line
you're giving them encouraging messages
right behind them is
500 pounds of drugs that they have
captured from this river that's right
they are incredible people
we've just spent some time together and
we had a whole group
at a meeting we also had that was just
covered on
your network and other networks and it's
incredible the job they do and we really
appreciate it
that's right they have a tremendous
amount of drugs that they just captured
right behind us and that's what they do
and if we had a barrier
a steel barrier concrete barrical
whatever you want it wouldn't uh have we
wouldn't have the problem
i have some shots that will show uh in
this people can walk across the river
and take them about what a minute and a
half
two minutes that's that's all it takes
and if they
there is no barrier all those drugs get
in if these guys
can't carry every every inch of of
you know the two thousand miles that's
right they have easy access into the
united states
we've built a lot of wall we've
renovated tremendous amount of wall with
money that we've already gotten
and we're continuing that but now we
really just want to get it going and
finish it up and we're going to build
the new wall
and it's common sense it really is when
you think of it whether you're
into the world of law enforcement like
these incredible folks behind us that
understand the wall so easily i mean it
would make their job so much better
and they could also go to other areas
because we have the wall you don't need
so many people
we would probably pay for that many
times in one year
if you think about just many times so
it's not a money thing it's a political
thing
they look at the 2020 race and they're
not feeling too good about it they'll do
whatever they can to win
i have tapes of maybe 20 democrats they
all use the same phrase manufactured
crisis
interestingly their best friends in the
media they're all using the same word
manufactured crisis so we have drug
cartels we have gangs that we're dealing
with
90 of america's heroin crossing our
southern border
and then of course we've had homicides
and
we've had sexual assaults 100 000
violent assaults
what do you say to that talking point
the media and the democrats are using
this is manufactured
well you know i watched last night i saw
on your show last night actually where
you had
anchor after anchors using the exact
same word it's
manufactured manually sounds like
they're in collusion a little collusion
that's the real collusion okay
that's the real collusion you take a
look because they all use the exact same
term i mean
literally the exact same two words but
they had manufactured i said where did
they come up with that it's a
manufactured crisis
no it's a manufactured sound bite
because it was just a sound bite
but every virtually every you know i
call it the
fake news i'm sure you haven't heard
because you're not fake news actually
you're real news
and there is some of that no there is
some of that around unfortunately and
these are great people
these are patriotic people that do it
correctly but you know when i hear that
terror manufactured and
you see every single group using it it's
very sad
we lose 300 americans a week
90 percent of the heroin comes into the
country um
but in the last two weeks we lost
officer singh
in california then pierce cochran i had
his parents on the show this year
i don't know how you recover after
losing a child killed by illegal
immigrants i've met and i've interviewed
so many angel moms and dads me too um
are they going to say that to them the
people that lost their loved ones their
sons their daughters
their parents well sean you know many of
the people that aren't getting their
check they get it they're going to get
it soon but
many of the people they're with us 100
percent they want us to win this battle
these people want us to win everybody
wants us to win this battle
it's common sense death is pouring
through we have
crime and death and it's not just at the
border they get through the border
but then they go all they filter into
the country and you have ms-13 gangs in
different places like los angeles and
you have gangs all over long island
which we're knocking the hell out of
but there should be no reason for us to
have to do this they shouldn't be
allowed in and if we had the barrier
they wouldn't be able to get in
okay so the point everybody that i have
met and spoke
spoken to they'll say tell the president
if you see him hold the line oh yeah
now you said earlier today that it's
likely
that you're very likely going to declare
a national emergency
how soon would that happen no if we
don't make a deal with congress most
likely i will do that i would
actually say i would i can't imagine any
reason why not because i'm allowed to do
it
the law is 100 percent on my side so if
we can't make a deal with congress then
we should be able to make a deal with
congress if you look
democrats in congress especially the new
ones coming in are starting to say wait
a minute we can't win this battle with
trump because of the fact that
it's just common sense how can we say
that a wall doesn't work
they show on helicopters empty fields
are people just running through
and you put a wall they can't run
through what are the options though if
you declare
a national emergency the pentagon also
has the funds available that they would
be able to help support the building of
the wall
if we don't make a deal with congress
which we should be able to really just
common sense and there's some compromise
needed
and look they know that the walls work
you know what works a wheel
and a wall it's they call it a medieval
thing well you know i'm looking at all
these very expensive cars all over here
loaded up with machine guns and every
single one of them has wheels
it's a wheel is an old thing and a wall
is a real thing there are two things
they work they work a wall would be so
effective it would solve
so many killings and so much death and
drugs and human trafficking
where they tape up women on their face
they tape them up and they put them in
the back of a car or a van
and they drive right through our border
i guess the next most important question
is
when you do that would you expect
they're gonna go judge shopping they'll
go to the ninth circuit they'll go to
california to start the process
uh is there are your attorneys telling
you there's an expedited way perhaps to
the supreme court
they are saying there possibly is and
hopefully we wouldn't even have to go
through the law is very clear i mean we
have the absolute right to
declare a national emergency and this is
security stuff this is a national
emergency
if you look at what's happening and you
just heard the statement they came in
last week or this week from pakistan and
different people
they got them you see sara carter last
night had people from bangladesh
absolutely and they come in through the
southern border because it's really
considered the space and the place
where they can get in and we want to
close it up these people have done the
greatest job it's
hard work and it could be a lot easier
and
it would be virtually 100 effective
and nancy and chuck know that but it's
politics it's about the 2020
campaign it's about running for
president that's what they're doing
they're already doing it
uh it's a shame we've got to put the
country first when you see
when you see the same democrats hillary
obama biden
schumer all supporting this you know in
2006 2013
they're not supporting it now is it
because you're the president and they
don't want you to get a win
shouldn't the win be about the country
being safer more secure they know what
i'm saying is 100
right and it's not only us it's
everybody saying it these people said
everybody says it
if you don't have a barrier whether it's
a steel barrier or a concrete wall
substantial and strong you're never
going to solve this problem
you're never going to solve it and i
don't need this look i could have done
something a lot easier i could have
enjoyed myself i haven't left
the white house because i'm waiting for
them to come over in a long time
you know that i stayed home for
christmas
i stayed at the white house for new
year's and i think he tweeted christmas
eve all alone where's chuck and nancy
my family i told them stay in florida
and enjoy yourselves but the fact is i
want to be
in washington i mean i consider it very
very important last question
timeline before you think you have to go
the route and declare a national
emergency well i think we're going to
see what happens over the next few days
they should do it immediately look we're
not going anywhere we're not changing
our mind because there's nothing to
change your mind about
the wall works it's not a question like
well maybe it won't work it'll work 100
now we're adding on to that equipment to
find drugs that are hidden in cars i
mean we have this incredible equipment
we're adding sensors we're adding drones
but
what we need is we need the the barrier
if we don't have a barrier if we don't
have a steel or concrete barrier
we're all wasting a lot of time and
lives will be saved
i know you're thought you're thinking
about the furloughed employees you
support them getting all their back pay
100 i support them tremendously but i
also support
families like the singh family
and others others by the hundreds and by
the thousands
that have lost somebody because our
policies are so bad and especially at
the southern border
they've lost and they've had people so
badly hurt but they've lost them they've
lost their lives they've lost
they've lost their heart out of the
family i support those families
the angel moms you know the angels very
well and so do i i support them too
does it mean a lot to you guys that the
president is down here yes sir
absolutely
yes and is he describing the situation
accurately
and if you get the wall the drugs will
stop you can stop the cartels
human trafficking drug trafficking the
gangs
yes it will help it will improve the
effect by what percent
like the chief said um the majority of
our traffic is uh
is usually coming through areas that
don't have a wall just like this uh 515
pounds of dough
mr president thanks for taking time
thank you very much thank you guys for
what you do too
thank you we appreciate it